وحرائقي كندا يخنق سكان امريكا الشماليه
ويتسبب في اسوا حاله تلوث في العالم عشرات
الملايين من سكان امريكا الشماليه تلقوا
تحذيرات من خطوره سوء جوده الهواء بسبب
الحرائق المنتشره في كندا ولا يزال الدخان
يغطي مناطق واسعه من اونتاريو وكبيك بينما
يغيم ضباب برتقالي اللون فوق معظم شمال
شرقي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واضحت
مدينه تورنتو ونيويورك ضمن المدن التي
تعاني من اسوا جوده هواء في العالم في هذا
الوقت
[موسيقى]
تلوث الهواء بسبب الحرائق يشكل تهديدا
حقيقيا لسكان امريكا الشماليه فنحو 100
مليون شخص في امريكا الشماليه مهددون
بالتعرض لاضرار صحيه حقيقيه بسبب سوء جوده
الهواء الجهات الرسميه بدورها سارعه الى
تحذير المواطنين حيث اصدرت وزاره البيئه
الكنديه اقوى تحذير بشان تلوث الهواء في
اوتاوا اعتبرته بانه يشكل خطرا شديدا
للغايه على صحه الناس في الوقت نفسه صنفت
وكاله حمايه البيئه الامريكيه جوده الهواء
في معظم انحاء الشمال الشرقي على انها غير
صحيه لا سيما لما يعانون بالفعل من مشكلات
في الجهاز التنفسي
احتياط وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات